oh yeah i kind of i said this like a
really long time ago uh i think with
just
joey and garn but one thing that uh
i don't think you were there that's why
but like
so you know how like a lot of youtubers
say i don't care about the views and the
views don't mean anything
i think it's a load of like [ __ ] at some
point because it's okay to care about
your views because that's like
being at a job and caring how many hours
you're getting how much you're getting
paid
it's okay to care about how many views
you're getting but
like also not being a dick about it i
think the important thing
is to think about the views after the
video's been made yeah yeah people
if you're going into a video with the
views in mind of like what's going to
get the views
yeah yeah you know in a way that you're
doing it purely for them
yeah and healthy way and i'm like
this is a popular topic this is probably
gonna have some interest but i'm not
thinking like
this needs to get views or it's done
yeah i'm not like i think that i look
after and if it does well i'm like sick
yeah that's bad i'm like well that sucks
but on to the next thing right
yeah i do sit here because because i i
feel like what i meant when i said that
because i have said
i don't care about the views yeah before
everyone's had that obligatory i'm gonna
defend myself
um i'm gonna die myself honestly i think
we've all said something everybody's
got where they're like guys i'm just
doing it because i love doing youtube i
don't care about the views
i've i've kept a saying to heart it's
like uh expect nothing and be pleasantly
surprised
because like it's it's gotten to the
point where you know i you
you every youtuber has this point when
they realize that
there there's a point in your life when
you realize hey your mental health is
really affected by how well your videos
yeah
that's really [ __ ] unhealthy yeah so
like i i had to
get to a point in youtube where i just
stopped looking at the views like
like i had to stop looking at the views
and just focus on the content that's
hard to do
it's it's it's just something i knew i
had to do because
we have this tool i don't know we've
talked about this before but we have the
children on youtube
where you upload a new video and youtube
will tell you how well it's performed
out of 10 against your last 10 videos
and
to me it's just a lose-lose game yeah
because you'd never
we should show the trash taste one right
now yeah it is it is the most
mind-breaking mechanic because it's
because
what i've realized is that it's you you
lose
most of the time right because if a
video is below
5 out of 10 you feel like [ __ ] the end
time i guess i'll die
exactly like we we meme it but like your
day can literally be ruined
oh yeah that's [ __ ] stupid by knowing
that your video performed nine or ten
they also give you like little [ __ ]
firework animations if you got number
one yeah yeah yeah
yeah but the thing is what i realized is
that if it's like a
four or five yeah you're just like okay
you don't feel good you feel relieved
yeah and that's just so unhealthy
because like that just means the only
time you actually feel good
is when you get the number one or two
which statistically speaking
you can't always get number one or two
and what's worse is like when you do get
that number one
the next thing you expect is well the
next video has to be number one as well
yeah like i just have to keep one-upping
myself and it never happens so like i
always leave
at least like four or five days before
taking the views of my video
right that gives me enough time that's
bro you must have known november easily
then
um i guess before we wrap this up what's
next for aki dearest what's the next
plans what are you going to do what are
your goals uh i'm working on the next on
the case video
all right i've been doing it i can't
give you anything i already would you
say you're more
like a short-term planner like you don't
really think about like like a year or
two from now you're like i'm just
thinking about what's going on the next
month
yeah i feel like it's just good to stay
in the in the present because that just
shapes out how your future is going to
be
damn that's a tv that's a t-shirt right
now
i was not expecting something i'm pretty
sure i'm pretty sure i've seen people
with chess pieces
i don't know i've been so stressed over
like what could have been or like what
did i do oh man i [ __ ] like did that
yesterday when
at the end of it it doesn't really
matter so i just feel like i just have
to fix it now
i feel like for every one thing i'm like
damn i could have done that i got like a
hundred other things on my holy [ __ ] i
was so lucky with this thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like ah you win
some you lose something yeah exactly